on the next all-new Rick and Morty Oh
flat tire how'd you get a flat tire in
space Rick Morty
get back in the car I'm not in danger
there's nothing out here early
everything is out here and unlike
everywhere else I'm too busy to help
right because you're always so helpful
yeah first sure getting in there right
on time with the dragon it was right
right at the peak of dragon hysteria
definitely a good idea always the show
that takes three years to make an
episode to leap on friends Emily gets a
dragon and things do not go well because
dragons are from fantasy and that
doesn't really play well with Rick's
sci-fi world you have no magic yeah I
know I have actual power not here you
don't
it's common episode about also like
relationships and toxic relationships
you suck I felt like that the dragon
kind of rebellion we must begin at 10:00
[ __ ] soul orgy ear honest ism in a way
is the path to defeat the patriarchy
this episode starts the conversation and
I think I should get probably some metal
for that a Webby I would accept that
Daytime Emmy okay I'll bite what's with
the talking cat the cat sub watt was an
attempt to just have fun the cat
represents that voice in your head in
the writers room it's like you're
overthinking it
just have fun it came from like it was
Disney movies like Oliver and company or
anything like that like they never
really explained why the cats can talk
the cat is here to save Jerry from
overthinking it where's the cat welcome
back everyone its Charlie this is gonna
be my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 5
trailer video there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything
we're doing a new round of the merch
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
evil Morty theory on the video I'll name
a new winner at the end of this - the
title of the episode is rattle star Rick
lactic a reference to Battlestar
Galactica it's not clear if it's a
reference to the original series or the
reboot series that Ronald D Moore did so
if you didn't see it earlier this year
Justin roiland implied in an interview
at Comic Con that this would be one of
the important canonical episodes of
season four with the big post credit
scene tag than some story teasers that
would carry over into season 5 he wasn't
clear if he was just miss speaking and
talking about the second half of season
4 or if it's legit something that we
won't see paid off till way later next
year in actual season 5 episodes they
still haven't set an exact date for the
second half of season 4 but I'm assuming
it's sometime in January till we hear
something otherwise the actual season
five episodes probably won't premiere
til either the next summer or later at
the end of next year like around the
same time that we got season 4 this year
if we get any updates or any official
information about that I'll be sure to
include it in one of my videos but in
the scene which kind of feels like the
cold open just based on the energy Rick
gets a flat tire in space for some
strange reason because apparently the
tires don't fully retract into the ship
and he has to stop change it they turned
it into a bit about how anything can
happen in space even getting bit by a
random snake that just happens to be
wearing a spacesuit for some strange
reason the joke kind of feels like it
was pitched by a writer who got bit by a
snake while changing their tire on the
side of the highway or something like
that this is the first time we've seen
those space suits but it's implied that
Rick's spaceship has hundreds of
different secret weapons and abilities
that they mostly just used for a comedy
at random times like the random meeseeks
box that he keeps in the glove
compartment that we just learned about
this season he probably still has his
ready to go because the only one that we
saw them used was the one inside fascist
Rick's spaceship and the whole idea is
that each version of Rick shares a lot
of similarities with only a few things
being different like being a wasp or a
teddy bear or a teddy bear that's a
fascist
morty being kind of a dumbass as usual
it doesn't see the danger of space
because he hasn't learned about all the
things that can happen in space it just
assumes that rick is being an [ __ ]
trying to tell him what to do sometimes
it can be hard to tell when rick is just
making fun of you and making stuff up
but most of the time when he warns
Morty's summer beth and jerry about
something it's because there is real
danger
so of course morty gets bit by a random
snake wearing a spacesuit there was more
this clip that was in the season 4
trailer where rick complains because
morty is whining too much about dying
I don't know I'm just usually around
people that die faster the snakes
spacesuit even has a little flag on it
it's cut off in frame so you can't tell
what it's a reference to but there was
also a longer version of this entire
clip from before they get out of the
spaceship but the clip that Adult Swim
used in one of the earlier videos is
heavily water marked with Warner Media
with warnings not to use it so I can't
just straight up drop the clip in this
video but it's Rick making this huge
Saturday Night Live joke when Morty gets
out of the ship against his orders he
says you young people think this space
is like Saturday Night Live you see it
every day you dream of being in it but
it dreams of removing all the air from
your body in making you float around it
for eternity
as a flash mummified corpse which is
also what space wants so get back in the
car so I'm kind of assuming that Dan
Harmon wrote that joke because it's so
utterly specific in its take down of
Saturday Night Live apparently Dan
Harmon not a big fan of Saturday Night
Live but beyond the Battlestar Galactica
and snakes reference I think this
episode is also supposed to be the
terminator parody with the snakes
because of a different clip from one of
the earlier trailers with some footage
that we still haven't seen during this
season yet it all the scenes from the
trailer that they dropped at the
beginning of this season is meant to be
real scenes from these episodes the
first five episodes the only time they
drop fake scenes is when it's for the
intro and only some of those scenes are
fake I actually think that we found our
first real intro scene for episode 5
here's the earlier trailer with that
Terminator snakes clip in it
and season four it's the forest of all
seasons because it's the fourth one it's
a lot different from season three we've
got a lot of a lot of shoot-'em-ups a
lot of laser shoot-'em-up so this is
just them doing the first Terminator
movie with snakes you have all these
Terminator snakes coming for more tea
then this one dressed like Kyle Reese
from the first movie coming to save him
for some reason so apparently more tea
is the Sarah Connor of this Terminator
equation but that also implies that the
Terminator snakes part of the new intro
is one of the real scenes keep in mind
though that there are still five more
episodes in season four technically so
there are a lot of these other intro
scenes that could wind up in episodes
but it's not clear why these cybernetic
snakes keep coming after Rick and Morty
who's behind them if they're doing a
terminator parody there has to be some
kind of Skynet if they're dropping a big
season five teaser does that mean it has
something to do with evil Morty he is
one of the few major ongoing canonical
villains of the series that they keep
bringing back and if it's gonna be a
Battlestar Galactica reference who is
going to be they're Cylons is that who
these terminator snakes are but they
hype the hell out of that upcoming tag
scene back at comic-con
I'm still like obsessed with this this
like tag you guys don't know man we have
a tag in season four that's good and I
wanna I wanted to record it and it's
like not I'm like it's I can't say it
but I don't get to record it but like
it's maybe my most favorite speech it's
so good it's so good then the response
it's just it's so good finale of season
four is really good yeah can we get
Kaname yeah you have so based on all the
stuff that they're hyping up in what we
know about the episode so far let me
know in the comments what do you think
is going on with the Terminator snakes
and what is that post credit scene going
to be teasing season 5 stuff they also
kind of imply that Beth has a special
story during the finale now I don't know
if that's gonna be the continuing saga
of is Beth a clone or not if that's
something that they'll go back to
because the way the writers talked about
it after season 3 is that they hadn't
really thought that far ahead they were
just kind of throwing that question out
there for fans to wonder about but there
was that whole storyline during season 3
episode 9 that was teasing the idea that
Beth had just as much potential as Rick
so Rick was telling her to just go out
and tie a bow on the universe go out and
have some fun and the ugly truth has
always been that I'm not that great a
guy and you're exactly like me so other
big question in the comments let me know
what you think that special Beth story
is going to be and when I do post my
episode 5 video next week I will rank
all the season 4 episodes so far there
was also a cool real-life Rick and Morty
thing that happened to me last week the
Adult Swim people the Rick and Morty
people and the people behind the turo
car service made an actual Morty card
that they let me drive so I'll post a
clip of that in my next Rick and Morty
bonus video which will probably be on
Friday if there any special Rick and
Morty bonus videos that you want me to
do just let me know in the comments big
reminder about the second half of season
4 I'm assuming little air sometimes
starting at the end of January until
they say otherwise but I'm hoping that
they drop an official promo just teasing
exactly when that's going to happen
sometime before the end of the year
Adult Swim can be kind of weird with the
way they release information sometimes
they don't tell you what's happening
till right before it happens which is
kind of annoying
and I'll say congratulations to the
giveaway winner for my last big Rick &
Morty video Almighty Sosa 300 please
email me on the about page my channel so
I can get your details
everyone click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 4 video and click
here for my new Mandalorian baby yoda
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you